واجهت صناعه السيارات تحديات ثقيله منذ
بدء وباء كورونا بالانتشار عالميا شركات
عده تاثرت بشده على راسها تسلى وجنرال
موتورز اضافه الى غيرهما لكن كان لشركه
صناعه السيارات الكهربائيه التي يراسها
الملياردير الامريكي الى الماسك النصيب
الاكبر من التاثر السلبي مع فقدها حول 85
مليار دولار من قيمتها السوقيه خلال اسبوع
واحد فقط خلال الشهر الحالي اي ديسمبر
خسرت تسلا حوالا 219 مليار دولار من
قيمتها السوقيه وهي قيمه عادل تقريبا قيمه
شركه تويوتا ثاني اكبر شركات السيارات
قيمه عالميه
اجتمعت الظروف القاهره وراء هذا تراجع
المخيف تخفيضات الاسعار وارتباك الانتاج
في الصين والخصومات الكبيره في الولايات
المتحده اضف الى ذلك تزايد قلقي
المستثمرين من ان ماسك يركز بشكل اكبر على
اصلاح تويتر بدلا من تسلا تعهد ماسك بانه
سيتوقف عن بيع اسهم تسلا على الاقل خلال
العام المقبل لكن الثقه بتصريحاته اذا
تعاهد بذلك لكن الثقه بتصريحاته تراجعت اذ
كان ادلى بتصريحات مماثله في ابريل اغسطس
وعاد وطرح اسهما من شركه للبيع تسلى ليست
صانع السيارات الوحيد الذي يواجه لحظات
حرجه العام المقبل فشركه جنرال موتورز
الامريكيه العملاقه تواجه تراجعا مخيفا في
المبيعات واتجهت للمره الاولى نحو انتاج
سيارات كهربائيه لكن مشروعها يواجهه
تحديات جمع في المقابل دفنت كل من فورد
وفولكس فاجن مشروعهما لانتاج سيارات ذاتيه
القياده هذا العام ولا يوجد ما يؤشر على
قرب العوده او تفعيل المشروع في وقت قريب
الوضع ليس افضل حالا في سوق السيارات
المستعمله فى شركه الاشهر في امريكا خسر
سهمها
98% من قيمته هذا العام
واقتربت الشركه من اعلان افلاسها قبل
توقيع اتفاق مع الدائنين والمتابعه
[موسيقى]
المتحدث باسم طالبان يقول نرفض اي تهديد
على خلفيه قراراتنا متعلقه بالنساء
بالعوده الى ازمه تسلا والتي اغلقت اسهمها
يوم الجمعه عند ادنى مستوى لها منذ اكثر
من عامين اذن اغلقت اسهمها عند ادنى مستوى
ويرجع المنتقدون سبب الى صفقه استحواذ
ماسك على تويتر بقيمه 44 مليار دولار كان
سهم شركه خفض الخميس ايضا بالنسبه التسعه
بالمئه بعد ما قالت انها ستقدم خصومات
بقيمه 7,500 دولار للمستهلكين الامريكيين
على اثنين من طرازاتها الاكثر مبيعا وهو
اعلام اثار المخاوف بشان طلب المستهلكين
بحسب صحيفه فاينال تايمز باع ماسك الذي
نزل مؤخرا عن منصب اغنى رجل في العالم ما
يقرب من ثلاثه وعشرين مليار دولار من
الاسهم منذ ان اعلن عن استحواله على تويتر
واثر غضب كبار المستثمرين الذين شعروا ان
الرجل تخلى عن شركه صناعه السيارات
التركيز على شركته الجديده تويتر وسيظل
عام 20 22 محفورا في ذاكره ماسك حتى وان
حاول نسيان بعض تفاصيله واحداثه فعلى قدر
مكان هذا العام حافلا على قدر ما كان حالا
بنجاحات عده حققها كان كذلك عاصفا بالنسبه
اليه لماموني به من خسائر ماليه وما خضه
من معارك قضائيه اذا حقق ماسك انجازات
رئيسيه من القيم بتوسع عالمي قوي لشركه
تسلا الى لاعب دوري داععم للمقاومه
الاوكرانيه في وجه الحرب الروسيه كما ان
الشرائه لتويتر اكثره قوه التاثير كبيره
لكنها فورس اعلنت ان الملياردير
لقب اغنى رجل في العالم بدايه ديسمبر بعد
تحمله ديونا ثقيله لشراء شركه التواصل
الاجتماعي الكبيره وبعد بيعه اسهما في
شركه سيارات الكهربائيه من اجل تمويل صفقه
تويتر التي بلغت قيمتها 44 مليار دولار